help me George Lucas you're my only hope
Darth Disney it's destroying the
expanded universe well please come back
George Lucas this is our most desperate
hour oh I felt a great disturbance in
the force as if thousands of story lines
cried out and were suddenly silenced the
Star Wars franchise is committing Canon
decide the fate of an entire universe is
at stake you got to understand the Star
Wars movies are the barest fraction of
Star Wars stories out there this
so-called expanded universe has existed
in comic books and novels and games for
decades and Lucasfilm is now air locking
it all the Fronde trilogy novels shadow
of the empire for nintendo 64 the
Tatooine manhunt module for the Star
Wars RPG the holiday special erased from
existence only a Sith Lord would decree
that everything except the Star Wars
films in the Clone Wars series did not
happen all future tie-in cartoons and
novels everything will be forced to
march in lockstep with the JJ Abrams
sequel films you know who else marched
in lockstep
in a new story group inside Lucasfilm
we'll make sure that all elements of the
Star Wars continuity fit together
normally I approve of an orderly and
cohesive continuity but this crisis on
infinite endures is deleting incidents
that are more interesting than almost
anything that happened in the movies no
expanded universe means Boba Fett never
escaped from the Sarlacc pit Luke
Skywalker never flirted with the
darkside and Han Solo never befriended
this guy right here
Jetson star hopper with the ears Oh
Darth Disney only you could be so bold
to think that I was cautiously
optimistic about your stewardship of
stuff I was far too trusting the
survival of the expanded universe is now
in the hands of Star Wars fans fan
fiction kept Star Trek alive through the
lean years we can do the same for Star
Wars the more you tighten your grip
Darth Disney the more expanded universe
stories will slip through your fingers
you may control the Canon but you will
never control the fanon your tightly
controlled continuity can't handle the
pulse-pounding exploits of identica snit
picture above the spectacle Jedi who
lectures the entire galaxy about how
lightsabers are scientifically
impossible and how you could actually
hear explosions in the vacuum of space
strong he is in the force of logic
what's your favorite expanded universe
story Angry Birds Star Wars doesn't
count let me know in the comments and
subscribe to the wire channel